what happens to us makes us who we are  wave to Daddy  it's in the past it doesn't mean you  need to bear it  just had a meeting with your publisher  we love pages runs  you want to write a new look true crime  scene writers have a way of spinning  things the way they want  I came to see my son why he obviously  hate me I was doing my best we're hiding  with your replacement family that's not  true remember this hold of this Mustang  it's not how I remember it because you  have a convenient way of remembering  things all the anger all the hatred safa  truck  I'm gonna scare away this measly scare  to you  my son ladies and gentlemen the  storyteller what a joke you people are  all fees you deserve to be played fallen  for this nonsense our father does what  he has to do to protect his children  if you understand that you understand  every day  you want to tell me so bad anything from  the truth